let's see if we could do a couple more
of these conic section identification
problems so I have this problem x
squared plus y squared minus 2x plus 4y
is equal to 4 and so the first thing I
like to do is just try to figure out
what type of conic section this will be
and we have our would be these are this
my x squared term my Y squared term
they're on the same side of the equation
and they both have positive coefficients
so this tells me that we're going to be
dealing with an ellipse and in this case
in particular the coefficients are the
same number they're both positive one so
this is going to tell me that is that
this is a circle so let's get it this
into standard form and try to graph this
circle so we're going to want to
complete the square so let's take the x
squared the X term since we get x
squared minus 2x plus something to
complete the square later on plus then
just do the y squared terms y squared
plus 4y plus something is equal to 4 and
now what do we add here we take half of
the minus 2 minus 1 square it that
becomes plus 1 add a 1 we have nothing
out here so we really just added 1 to
the left hand side of this equation so
we have to add 1 to the right hand side
and here we take half of 4 half of 4 is
2 2 squared is 4 put a 4 here so you
have to add a 4 to the right hand side
as well and we actually did add just a 4
because there's nothing multiplying the
4 out here and so this becomes X minus 1
squared plus y plus 2 squared is equal
to 4 plus 1 plus 4 is equal to 9 and
there you have it we have in the
standard form of a circle you remember
that if a circle is centered at 0 the
standard form would be x squared plus y
squared is equal to R squared so this is
R squared this is the radius squared so
that tells us the radius of the circle
three and was just shifted so that its
origin instead of being at zero zero is
at the point one minus two and the
reason we've got one minus two we just
have to think about what makes this
whole expression equal zero in this case
it was the origin in this case it's X
equal one x equals one and what makes
this whole expression equal zero in this
case it was y is equal to zero in this
case it's y is equal to minus two so
that's our center that's our radius and
we're ready to graph graph this circle
so it's at let me see it is that I
should graph the circle first that's
fair enough if I actually want to just
graph the circle so it's going to be at
1 minus 2 so 1 minus 2 so it's going to
be like down here so this it's going to
come this circle is going to start there
yes Center let's try my best is going to
be at 1 and then you go one two and so
that's pretty close to its center maybe
I should go one two that's its center
right there at one minus two and then
it's radius is three so this distance
right here is three in any direction
it's three and that is three fair enough
that was a pretty straightforward
problem circles in some ways or the
straight are the simplest and remember I
said it's going to be an ellipse and you
say oh this is the standard formula for
an ellipse just as a refresher if you
divide both sides of this equation by
nine what do you get you get X minus 1
squared over 9 plus y plus 2 squared
over 9 is equal to 1
and then you see that the the horizontal
axis
I guess we're against the horizontal
diameter is going to be 3 and the or the
horizontal radius is going to be 3 and
the vertical race it's also going to be
3 because the radius never changes in
this ellipse which is really a circle
let's do one more just so make sure you
you know this stuff cold so I have 2x
squared plus
I plus 12 X plus 16 is equal to zero
let's look at the x squared and the y
squared terms there's an x squared term
but I don't see a y squared term so this
is a bit of a conundrum and this will
lead us to the fourth of our conic
sections which I talked about in the
first video but we haven't really
touched on yet with that's the parabola
and how do I know it's a parabola well I
mean you you're familiar and I'll go
more in future videos on all the
different ways that a parabola comes
about and how is the you know is that
all the points equidistant between one
point in a line and all of that but you
know just on very simple ways you
recognize is kind of the most simple
parabola is y is equal to x squared that
parabola looks something like this right
where this where it's minimum point or
its vertex is that the origin or if you
have a parabola like X is equal to Y
squared that looks something like this
where it's a sideways version of that
one where once again its vertex is at
the origin and just out of out of
interest actually I won't go there yet
but actually well no I'll just so we
know that this is a parabola because we
have a Y and we have an x squared right
there different degrees there's no
there's no there's no second degree term
of the Y and just to put this in a form
this familiar to you let's just subtract
everything but the Y from the left hand
side so you get Y is equal to minus 2x
squared minus 12x minus 16 and this is
kind of the the traditional form that
you're familiar with you're probably
even used to finding the zeros of this
parabola we could do that right now we
could say okay when does this equation
intersect the x axis the x axis is when
y is equal to zero set that equal to
zero you get minus 2x squared minus 12x
minus 16 or this is different than what
we normally do normally I would
immediately break into completing the
square but I just want to figure out the
zeroes of this parabola first so this is
zero is equal to minus two times
factoring out - do you get X plus six X
plus eight so zero is equal to minus two
times X plus two times X plus four just
factor
that and so for this whole thing to be
zero either this is 0 or that is 0 and
so it's either X plus 2 is equal to 0 or
X plus 4 is equal to 0 so X is equal to
minus 2 and X is equal to minus 4 that's
the two zeros of this parabola so we
immediately know one thing about this
parabola and we've you've probably
already done this in your algebra
classes if we were to draw the x axis if
we were to draw the x axis it intersects
the x axis at 1 and -2 and 3 and minus 4
so that's all we know about this right
now so let's see if we can use some of
our completing the square skills with
the conic sections we've done so far to
come up with a little bit more
information about this parabola so let's
try to complete the square with it I'll
rewrite it down here so it's y is equal
to this is what I'm dealing with
and let me just take the X terms by
themselves and factor out the -2 minus 2
times x squared plus 6x I'm going to add
something else and then I have a minus
16 over there to make this a cup of a
perfect square I have to take half of
this half of the 6 half of the 6 is 3 3
squared is 9 if I add 9 to the
right-hand side of the equation remember
I didn't just add 9 this 9 times minus 2
I'm adding so if I subtract that's minus
18 if I subtract 18 from the right-hand
side I also have to do it from the
left-hand side
so subtract 18 there and not my equation
becomes Y minus 18 is equal to minus 2
times what is this this is X plus 3
squared minus 16 and let's just get it
in a form that we might start
recognizing from our conic sections
let's add 16 to both sides so you add 16
to both sides Y minus 18 plus 16 is
going to be Y minus 2 put parentheses
around that is equal to minus 2 times X
plus 3 squared and now you might wonder
why I put it in this
Arman and and I did because this will
help us this is kind of the same pattern
that you see with all of the other conic
sections like if I were to tell you to
graph you know y is equal to x squared y
is equal to x squared it would look
something like let me draw the whoops
let me draw some axes here y equals x
squared looks something like this it
looks like a poor I mean it's a parabola
with the vertex at 0 or its minimum
point and that's what the vertex is is
the minimum point of or the maximum
point of the parabola we'll talk more
about that you learn a lot more about
that when we when we go into calculus
but I think you can kind of recognize at
the bottom of the U or the top of the U
if I were to draw if I wanted to draw Y
is equal to minus x squared and you
could plot some points but it looks
something like that
if I were to try to graph y is equal to
2x squared it would just be like the y
is equal to x squared would go up twice
as fast it would look something like
that
so the vertex at the origin and finally
if I were to graph y is equal to minus
2x squared it would look something like
this it would point it would open
downward and go down twice as fast now
this one this equation that we ended up
with right here this is the same thing
as Y is equal to minus 2 x squared and
it's the same general shape but stead of
its vertex or its center or it's kind of
starting point or whatever you want to
call it to be at the origin it shifted
now you say what Y value makes this term
0 what's Y is equal to 2 just fly you
know in this case what Y value makes
this 0 well it's 0 here because we were
at the origin and here what x value
makes this 0 is X is equal to minus 3 so
this gives us information about where
the vertex is it's at - it's at X is
equal to minus 3 y is equal to 2 so said
X is equal to 1 2 3 y is equal to 1 -
it's right there we already know those
two points because we figured out it's 0
but even if we didn't know those two
points we know that this has the same
general shape as Y is equal to minus 2 x
squared so it's going to open
word like this and a little bit faster
than Y is equal to minus x squared so
it's going to look like this I mean oh
it goes to that point and we know goes
through that point there you go
so we've touched on every every conic
section and in the next few videos I'll
go into a little bit more depth of kind
of the theory behind conic sections and
how they came about and all of that but
I think now you're ready to tackle a lot
of what you might actually see on your
algebra tests see you soon